I want to talk about this lev par nice
guy are you following this uh yeah of
course yeah
president Trump still denies knowing
this Ukrainian American named Lev Parnas
says he doesn't know him never met him
left Parnassus at the center of the
Ukrainian aid scandal and some people
have described him as a bagman for Rudy
Giuliani and Trump just keeps saying I
don't know him
I don't know him I don't know him except
that one time in this photo this is real
yeah and this one okay and this one yeah
that's these are yeah it's nuts
yeah sanity then it gets worse this one
just came out they went to the state
yeah and then there's this one yeah it
was then apparently they went to the
prom together so I don't know
good compromise that wait I want to see
the prom photo again I really like that
then live obviously into the Beatles
yeah yeah who's his Beatles face